Earlier, I mentioned it's
important to make sure that
the content fits within the viewport
to prevent horizontal scrolling.
You should use relative units
when specifying widths for
elements to prevent them from
accidentally overflowing the viewport.
Keep in mind, CSS does allow
content to overflow it's container.
So if you don't specify a size and,
say, for
example the image is bigger than
the container, it will overflow.
You can save yourself some headache, and
prevent this from happening by
setting a max width of 100%.
In fact, I recommend adding a catch
all in your main CSS for image,
embed, object and video elements,
that sets this, just to be safe.